some places in the solar system have
some pretty expensive rain falling on
their surface why not see if we could
bring that home what would it take for
Earth to have million-dollar hail
dropping from the sky how rich would it
make you and why would you need medieval
armor to survive this is what if and
here's what would happen if it rains
diamonds it rains diamonds on Saturn
Jupiter and maybe on Uranus and Neptune
2 on Saturn it's the combination of
lightning carbon and atmospheric
pressure that makes diamonds drop from
the sky first dramatic lightning storms
and turn methane in Saturn's atmosphere
into graphite then the very high
atmospheric pressure turns the graphite
into diamonds
then the uncut gems rained down to
Saturn Center until they get liquefied
by the planets extreme temperatures now
that we know the recipe
how would we go about pulling this off
on our planet and what would it be like
to live on a planet with such precious
precipitations you know diamonds are
some of the hardest materials found on
earth the only thing that can scratch a
diamond is another diamond
now imagine those gemstones falling down
from the sky there wouldn't be anything
like that more like this
a diamond drain would bring total
destruction down to earth the falling
gems would be tiny like a pebble hard
but small like a baseball but because of
their sharp jagged edges and because of
the speed at which diamonds would be
falling from the sky even the tiniest
diamond hitting your car would be like
hitting it with a baseball bat there we
go well better they break all your car
windows and windows of your home they
damaged streets and highways and they
could injure or even kill you
meteorologists would have a hard time
predicting a Joule thunderstorm if you
wanted to stay safe you wouldn't leave
your house without a helmet or maybe
even metal clothes it would be awkward
to walk around in those but at least you
wouldn't get killed by a diamond Saturn
produces almost 1 million kilograms of
diamonds every year if the earth had
such a rich supply of gems they'd stop
being so rare and desirable and their
market price would plunge down at least
you could afford to give your girlfriend
an engagement ring with one big diamond
on it
but diamonds wouldn't just be used in
jewelry because of their abundance we
would start using them for anything we
could think of we build diamond houses
design diamond furniture we could even
pave our roads with diamonds what a
shiny world it would be unfortunately
getting hit by a diamond wouldn't be
your biggest concern as we figured
earlier an important ingredient for a
diamond drain is methane on earth the
amount of methane in the atmosphere is
equivalent to two cups of water in a
swimming pool plus to turn methane into
graphite and then into diamonds
Earth's atmospheric pressure would need
to be about 1,000 times higher if it
rained diamonds on earth you wouldn't be
around to see it
all of humanity
left to suffocate another one if another
how to die scenario luckily there's more
than one spectacular way to make the
earth more like other places in the
solar system but that's a story for
another what if
you